the Trump administration says it will
ignore and remember a UN vote to condemn
its recognition of Jerusalem as Israel's
capital in a non-binding resolution 128
Nations denounced the decision calling
it null and void just nine countries
voted to support the US while 35 others
abstained major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning good morning
when President Trump announced on
December 6 that he was moving the United
States Embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem and recognizing Jerusalem as
Israel's capital he said it was simply
following through on a law Bill Clinton
signed in 1995 true but no president
before mr. Trump did what that law said
leaving the status of Jerusalem to peace
talks between the Israelis and
Palestinians the United Nations vote
amplifies critics who believe mr.
Trump's move has jeopardized that very
peace process the United States will
remember this day in which it was
singled out for attack president Trump's
ambassador to the United Nations warned
two member countries that condemning us
solidarity with the Israeli government
would have consequences this vote will
be remembered 128 countries ignored the
warning among them US allies Britain
France Germany Italy and Japan during
the US and Israel were only seven other
countries Guatemala Honduras Marshall
Islands Micronesia Nauru Palau and Togo
combined population 33 million and
recipients of more than six hundred
eighty million dollars in US aid they
take hundreds of millions of dollars and
even billions of dollars and then they
vote against us president Trump said
Wednesday the US could cut off funding
to countries that Cross him let him vote
against us will save a lot President
Obama's CIA director John Brennan called
the president's threat to retaliate
beyond outrageous and said mr. Trump
showed qualities quote found in
narcissistic vengeful autocrats it is
time to officially recognize Jerusalem
as the capital of Israel the president's
decision to recognize Jerusalem
and his intention to move the US Embassy
there set off days of protests and
earned condemnation from Arab nations
and European allies America will put our
embassy in Jerusalem no vote in the
United Nations will make any difference
on that the State Department has said it
has not identified which nations if any
it will penalize over this non-binding
vote in the United Nations or next year
the United States is scheduled to dole
out just under 26 billion dollars in
foreign aid Gail say Merry Christmas to
the National Park Service
Merry Christmas national park service
and merry Christmas to you too major
Garrett thank you